[Music]
Jesus was born in a manger and Silicon
Valley was born in a garage with the
venture capital industry as its father
and Stanford University as its mother
this region once home to plum orchards
and cattle ranches became the fertile
ground for the world's greatest
technological innovations throughout the
20th century
The Legend of Silicon Valley grew
attracting apostles and engineers from
all across the land to join in the great
salvation that would be brought on by
computers and the Internet
that is until tragically in 2001
irrational exuberance condemned the
Silicon Valley bubble to pop for three
years the valley lay dormant trillions
were lost or so it seemed until in 2004
Silicon Valley miraculously rose again
with the IPO of Google incorporated thus
is the origin story for Silicon Valley
the modern Messiah of the world's most
powerful religion capitalism every
culture has its own mythology the
fundamentally normative stories that
preserve and perpetuate the values that
define the culture itself and Silicon
Valley's in a different we have our
god-like founders our visionary prophets
our epic disruptors do it and Packard
building their first audio oscillator in
a Palo Alto garage
Bill Gates selling das to IBM but
retaining the licensing race mark
zuckerberg bringing his band of misfits
to the valley and hacking together the
facebook but these myths have
consequences the myths of Silicon Valley
and more specifically the archetypes who
inhabit these myths form a sort of
magnetic field that tugs on the tech
industry's moral compass shaping where
we work what we build and how we lead
so I want to critically examine the
nature and the influence of three of
these powerful Silicon Valley archetypes
the founder the Oracle and the disruptor
our first Silicon Valley archetype is
the hero himself the technological
ubermensch the Superman the founder who
is this mythical founder well they start
their career as a college dropout famed
venture capitalist Peter Thiel was
giving high school students $100,000
grants to start companies instead of
wasting their time in college the
founder is ruthlessly efficient they
don't have time to eat meals so they
drink Soylent they can't waste precious
mental cycles trying to figure out what
to wear every day so they wear the same
t-shirt and hoodie and jeans and the
founder must be ruthlessly efficient
because they're frequently the CEO of
two or three or four different companies
the soul and lifeblood of their
respective organizations utterly
irreplaceable but I ask you to consider
what kind of future does the Silicon
Valley founder create for the founder
there's no room for empathy only
efficiency there are no people problems
only engineering problems everything has
an optimal measurable solution and so
our technology companies end up building
products that optimized for engagement
with notifications and pings vying for
every second of our waking attention
colors tuned to make us click positive
feedback loops of likes triggering our
dopamine response like slot machines and
cigarettes to have us tap again and
again and again and so we end up with
social networks that leave us not
connected but depressed with news that
leaves us not informed but angry with
mobile games that leave us not
entertained but addicted there are only
two types of pushers of product that
call their company their customers users
techies and drug dealers
our second Silicon Valley archetype is
the Oracle the Oracle is the future seer
the thought leader the visionary who can
predict the technological forces that
will shape our future world perhaps the
most recent famous Silicon Valley
prophecy comes from the Gospel of Mark
Andreessen in The Wall Street Journal in
2011 the Netscape founder and venture
capitalist wrote that software is eating
the world and it's not just individuals
who serve as the Silicon Valley Oracle
the valley as a whole perpetuates this
sort of predictive zeitgeist for what
will obviously be the next big thing
machine learning self driving cars
cryptocurrency drones chat BOTS and so
the rest of the world looks to the
Silicon Valley meta Oracle to see where
to invest or where to brace for impact
but again what kind of future does the
Silicon Valley Oracle create so much of
Silicon Valley prediction is predicated
on this notion of technological
inevitability that the inexorable march
of progress is an unstoppable force of
the universe and your only options as an
individual are to either invest or get
out of the way Automation is going to
take your job so you better learn to
code your digital footprint is
everywhere so you better reconsider of
privacy electric scooters are the next
big advance in mobility so you better
hop on or get left behind
but the Silicon Valley Oracle believes
in these things coming true and they
very much well may come true but is the
attitude of the Oracle of inevitability
that removes human agency and thus human
responsibility from the future that we
create it is not a human hand so this
logic goes but the invisible hand on the
wheel that steers the ship of progress
who will be the winners in this
supposedly inevitable future and who
will be left behind our third and final
Silicon Valley archetype is the
disruptor Silicon Valley is obsessed
with disruption
of innovative new technologies coming in
and turning existing industries upside
down the preeminent global startup
conference is called TechCrunch Disrupt
there are firms dedicated to disruption
Consulting at USC today you can get a
degree in disruptive innovation
perhaps the god-king of recent Silicon
Valley disruption is uber the taxi
industry in its anti diluvian period is
rife with inefficiency in comes uber you
can summon a car at the touch of a
button the status quo is upended and the
disrupter reigns supreme
but what kind of future does the Silicon
Valley disrupter create the disruptor in
these myths is the deliver of a sort of
Darwinian justice that the old order
content in its dominance and stagnation
deserves to be taken down
and so the disruptor in these myths
doesn't and indeed mustn't think too
hard about the collateral damage of
their disruption yeah with Silicon
Valley companies are disrupting today is
no longer just old hard drives its
people it's labor markets it's education
its health care and today's Silicon
Valley disrupter is looking less and
less like the creator of a fundamentally
new technology and more and more like an
adept user of venture capital dollars to
undercut prices and dodge regulation and
avoid labor laws and exploit public
spaces and under pay workers and
strongarm suppliers and achieve
monopolies what Silicon Valley so
mythologize --is as disruptive
innovation is robber baron capitalism
reborn in the mobile era these three
archetypes the founder the Oracle and
the disruptor form the foundations of
today's Silicon Valley institutions and
culture and values but these myths are
trapped in a different era they're
trapped in an era of silicon they're
trapped in an era of wafers and chips of
servers and cell phones our world has
changed the problems that Silicon Valley
tackles today are of a much more human
form of relationships of community of
biology of the nature of
itself our old myths are not fit for
this new era so who is it that we want
to be doing the creating that we want to
deliver us into a future built for
everyone and not just a select few
I want the humanist who focuses not on
achieving growth but on achieving
sustainability who doesn't just optimize
for engagement but optimizes for empathy
for whom diversity and inclusion don't
just make their company stronger but
make society stronger
I want the artist who doesn't just see
technology as instrumental and
commercial but as inspirational and
creative who doesn't just look for
solutions that are optimal but that are
beautiful for whom progress means not
achieving greater returns but achieving
greater global understanding and I want
the synthesizer who doesn't just look to
technology as the solution to every
problem but to community or to
government or to education for whom
technology is not an end in and of
itself but just one of many different
means for fulfilling our humanity's
greatest potential Silicon Valley will
always represent a great force for
change but I believe that all of us in
the valley are fundamentally responsible
for the shape that that change takes but
Silicon Valley needs new myths we need
new heroes and I believe that those
heroes could be all of you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]